(upbeat music)
- I haven't heard that salt
makes coffee less bitter.
I have heard that salt
makes everything better.
- I have heard that salt
makes coffee less bitter,
but I've not actually tried it.
- No, I've never heard that.
How much salt do you have to put in?
(upbeat music)
Oh, it's like a blind test.
Oh, I see, okay.
- Very smooth, a little nutty.
- It's pretty bitter,
but not like that bitter.
It's definitely like tolerable
as a cup of black coffee.
- I think this one does have salt in it
'cause that's not very bitter.
- Is this the one with salt in it?
- This tastes worse for me.
- Okay, I take it back.
That one definitely has salt in it.
- Yeah, it definitely tastes like,
slightly less bitter.
- That makes it less bitter
but it also makes it like, salty.
- Salt, I think you failed.
- The salt hack works.
- I like my coffee black.
Black, rich.
Just ferocious.
I like my coffee to punch me
in the dick in the morning!
Yeah!